vous
maria pacôme comédienne maria pacôme
auteurs maria pacôme joue sa propre
pièce dans un théâtre parisien connu
mais surtout maria pacôme lance un
nouvel espoir du théâtre ici pour un
saisissant teddy sa grande comedian is
it
en tout les soirs en scène fait son
petit numéro regarde même pas le public
elle est très bien et très mec ses
partenaires elle leur shit pas leurs
effets 1
eh bien j'ai un titre récompense très
ferme du ouvert et curieux
on a eu quelques problèmes au départ
parce qu'on se demandait quel chien à
les prendre et sans les prendre un chien
dressé fallait qu'ils rendent et pas
grand-chose à faire enfin quand même
fallait que ce soit très bien fait on a
réfléchi pendant longtemps et qu un jour
il y avait collecté cèdre qui joue avec
nous qui a fait cette bête est un
malinois est très turbulente disais pour
possible ils disent ne pas pouvoir faire
ça il peut y rentrer un jour on a essayé
pour la garder les chiens du gardien
aussi qu'on avait essayé très il a passé
une audition lamentable alors bon peuple
s'il ya aussi les chiens de daniel
auteuil sacrée carte ati plein caméras
chez les sportifs eux cabotine on est
trois chiens qui ont passé l'audition et
c'est celle-là c'est la star la plus
belle ailleurs détroit je pense que la
fesse conservatoire certainement mais
elle est très douée c'est certain mais
on voit bien quand même qu'elle a elle a
fait des études classiques ça c'est
certain
aziz a les genoux faire un petit peu
bien là qu'est la glisse il est bien là
où la piazza roulements par me repens
sait jamais avec elle et oui voilà la
bonne l'achat
e
vous inquiétez pas le mort que les
fesses du facteur et elle fait la fête
aux vagabonds
allez vas te coucher toit sans sa
demeure encore les traits tirés
1 yalla yalla tient pas là après moi
céline est une pièce de moi qui est
excellent en haïti ce qu'elle est belle
ma pièce mots le très bonne voie là elle
apprécie tout le monde apprécie à la
gros bisou au théâtre des nouveautés
apprends-moi tellines on l'a déjà dit on
recommande son recommence on s'en lasse
pas allez vial et vial havre a suffi au
monde
voilà mon salut on salue on salue on
salue pas imbécile
c'est à venir
de toutes les pièces
je ne digère pas très bien qui fera une
raison et les eaux du ruisseau paul
avait bien besoin de lui parler d'une
cuisse de poulet twente s'est fait
servir une fille de poulet à 2 heures du
matin à une carcasse argueil ya une
question
c'était ce que tu as fait c'est trop nul
or ça n'est pas peur il mort que les
faces du facteur elle fait la fête aux
vagabonds
non elle est affectueuse sénat noël et
surtout boulimique lé bas à la baisse
elle va te coucher sur sa couche et va
te coucher il va te coucher quand ça
demain devant les possibles
m non il s'est déjà couché près de la
halle et